we start with some breaking news rescue
operations are underway in parts of the
philippines that have been hit by one of
the strongest storms in the world this
year
tens of thousands of people are being
moved to emergency shelters in southern
and central parts of the country
officials say about ten thousand
villages are in the projected path of
the typhoon jamella ellen dogan has more
from manila
what we are seeing basically whatever it
is that are made available at this point
are just snippets of what's actually
happening at the moment um you know
typhoon rai made landfall on chargaw
island you know a known tourist
destination on the eastern part of the
mindanao region and it is a slow moving
typhoon which means that it's going to
batter a lot of the coastal and
agricultural communities in this part
of um of of of of the philippines and we
know that a lot of the aids usually are
already pre-positioned in a country like
the philippines with more than 7 000
islands but again the the succeeding um
rescue and retrieval operations if there
will be and additional response teams
that will be coming from different areas
will really depend on areas that are hit
the most so this is quite a waiting game
for the national government it's going
to be sending aid from manila and the
regional networks are positioned to help
with emergency response the strongest
storm to ever hit on global record is
typhoon haiyan in 2013 and since then
we've seen efforts to institutionalize
um emergency preparations disaster
response but as you see at this point as
mentioned previously the big issue here
is that now there is a difference when
it comes to the disaster landscape
because of the pandemic you know um when
we when the government conducts um
rescue and uh evacuation efforts that
means that residents are evacuated in
temporary shelters like public schools
and you know um open government
facilities but then they can't really
stay too long because of the minimum
health protocol required by the
philippine government so what happens
then two residents who've lost their
homes in many of these areas so so that
coupled with the economic recession
which means that you know a lot of these
areas uh rural areas that are already
badly hit by typhoon banco alas we will
will most likely suffer against